i'm ben um i work at mode uh we build a
bi analytics product also as sean said
uh if like this is stuff you're
interested in i yell a lot of the
internet about these sorts of things um
so uh when i first submitted this talk
uh six months ago or so for the first
round of data council that didn't happen
uh this is what i submitted
and so the sort of story that goes
through with this talk is i was going to
talk about uh what is an olap cube
i was going to talk about why they went
away i was going to talk about why they
came back
and i was going to say it's like a
pretty good reboot like this is a good
thing we should be excited about our
left cube coming back
uh i felt pretty good about this story
but then over the course of the next six
months uh it turns out i didn't feel so
good about the story uh i talked to some
people they actually did change my mind
uh so turns out that's not the story i
want to tell like oops um
so the new story i'm going to talk about
is what is an olap cube why they went
away why they came back
and why it's not such a good reboot uh
and why this is actually a thing that we
should be we should be a little bit
worried about um so that's sort of the
story of of what this is uh to start off
what's an olap cube if you wanna know
what an olap cube is i would recommend
you reading this blog post by claire
carroll this is the blog post uh it goes
into very accessible detail about what
an olap cube actually is
the the short answer of this of of what
is an olap cube is it's a table
all it is is a table structured in a
very particular way uh it's easy to
think of these things as like something
fancy and some special technology and
things like that in reality it's just a
table used for a particular thing
and so to explain that i want to use the
context of imagining that you work at
lego
this is lego's headquarters which is a
cool office i didn't know this until i
started digging up pictures for this
um so suppose you work at lego
and you're like some big boss man at
lego
and so you want to figure out like how
people are actually buying legos
and suppose also this is in the 90s
because you're using olap cubes and
that's when no lab cubes were popular
so how would you actually answer
questions about whether or not people
are buying legos and where they're
buying them those sorts of things
you could imagine you would have a bunch
of questions you'd have questions like
how much money do we make in california
how much money do we make in ohio how
much money do we make in ohio in january
all these sort of like basic business
reporting questions that would be the
sort of things you need to to make
decisions
to answer these questions lego probably
has or hopefully has like a big log of
all of the times that people buy legos
so they've got this big table this is a
straightforward table to understand uh
it's one row per purchase and it's got
some details about the purchase like the
item and the store and the state and how
much it cost and all those sorts of
things
these prices seem way low for how much
legos cost
and so this is how you would actually do
this sort of reporting
so the problem here though is lego sells
a lot of legos uh according to this
random pdf that i found on the internet
uh called the art of the brick one of
the quirky facts uh about legos is that
they sell seven a second
uh these are the best seven legos that
were made before 2000 this is a stand i
will take here um
so they sell seven a second so if you do
the math that's like 200 million or so
legos a year
and so if you are asking questions like
these in the 90s on top of 200 or
million or so transactions that's going
to take a really long time like
databases could not handle that that
well certainly couldn't handle it that
well if you're running it on like your
local computer trying to put in
something like excel that doesn't work
like you can't actually do a bunch of
math on top of records that large in on
computers of that age
um so what do you do instead
what they would do is instead of saying
we're going to compute it directly on
top of this raw transaction log
we will instead create an olap cube
uh and so an olap cube is a roll-up of
that data aggregated by different
dimensions that you actually want to
look at it with and so there are kind of
two sections to this thing
the left side and blue are what are
called dimensions
these are basically groupings that you
could say okay we want to look at it
transactions by month we want to look at
them by state you can imagine other
things here as well uh and then the
green part of this is measures and so
these are like metrics these are how
much did we sell the number of items
those sorts of things and so what you
can do with this is now you can actually
roll this up again you can basically
turn this into a pivot table and compute
the sort of questions that were being
asked by the lego dude earlier
so if you want to look at say the number
of like the average sales by state you
can pretty easily pivot this table
around to get average sales by state if
you want to look at the total sales by
state same thing if you want to look at
sales by month you can do that or you
can create like fancier pivots that are
that are kind of computing the same
stuff
and so the idea here is now to be able
to run these things it's way faster
because you're not having to run all
these calculations on top of that 200
million row table
so sort of like graphically how that
looks
you've got this raw data you now have an
olap cube that pre-aggregates this data
into this like nice condensed form
and then when you want to do reporting
you aggregate it again to be able to
actually aggregate to the metrics that
you want and when you do that it's just
a loop between the reporting layer and
the olap cube itself that you never
actually have to go back to to the 200
million rows
so there's some benefits to this uh one
of those is you can ask a bunch of
questions quickly and when you think
about like the point of business
analytics you think about what people
are trying to do when they're trying to
make decisions with this stuff they want
to be able to iterate through these
questions and so it's important to be
able to not take 10 minutes for each one
of these things to come back and so now
you can actually do that do that quickly
there's another benefit to this too
which is this thing actually is
consistent so for anybody who's actually
trying to do business reporting you
probably realize like it's difficult to
actually make metrics consistent they
get sort of created in a bunch of
different places uh by using an olap
cube you basically compute those things
once and then build a bunch of reports
on top of the intermediate olap cube and
so now you have consistently calculated
metrics
there's one big downside though and if
you like read anything about olap cubes
it will very much point these things out
uh which is you have to pre-compute
everything like you don't actually have
access to this raw data anymore you only
have access to this intermediate step
and that requires you to actually
pre-compute it and kind of pre-define
the questions you want to ask
and so you're pretty limited what you
can do here and so by like by way of
example this was the original olap cube
that i showed you it's i don't know it's
like what 12 rows long um it's got only
two dimensions and one measure you might
add other measures so you might add the
number of items sold or you might add
like the total tax paid or whatever else
these things don't actually add that
much like this cube's not getting that
much bigger by just adding it out
horizontally you're not actually adding
new rows but if you add new dimensions
it becomes this kind of like
combinatorical explosion or each one of
those things you have to recompute like
the entire each possible aggregation and
so if you want to add the store id for
where these legos were purchased you can
see this table starts to blow up
and so to get a sense of what how big
this actually can get uh in 1999 i did
some more digging on lego history there
were 4 597 total lego sets that you
could buy
if they sold those in 50 states across
52 weeks then this actually comes out to
close to 12 million possible
combinations and so just reporting
across three dimensions and only the
time granularity of weak and only like
the location granularity of state
you actually probably can't do much on
top of this in in something like excel
in that age so again very slow so that's
really like the constraint of what an
olap cube is is you can't put that much
in it because these things can blow up
really fast
but they provide these other benefits so
to kind of summarize that uh people can
answer questions quickly with them
metrics computed consistently
everything has to be pre-computed
there's actually no like a second
problem here that people don't often
talk about about olap cubes which kind
of is part of the reason you have to
answer the question of like what is an
olap cube
and that's that olap cubes are actually
really unintuitive to use
um that they aren't something that make
a lot of sense to people are trying to
consume them they might make sense sort
of in the way that you're trying to use
them here but they don't actually make
sense as a way to distribute data to
other people around the organization
so to explain that again using another
lego example
imagine that you're like in a board
meeting somebody's trying to ask a bunch
of questions you're putting together
reports for for sort of this basic
business reporting like open bugs or
whatever they have on that white board
um the kinds of questions that people
are going to ask for this sort of thing
for this kind of reporting are going to
be structured like this they're going to
be like how many bricks did we sell what
is our revenue and they may get more
detailed than this they may be what is
our revenue by week by the set theme in
europe like they will be these sort of
different drill downs into this number
but fundamentally what this question is
about is about a metric it's about this
metric at the top and sort of in this
sentence in all of these sentences about
how people are asking questions
the metric is the object of the sentence
and this is like i'm from the south we
didn't diagram sentences in the south uh
this is my attempt to diagram a sentence
i think that's like the i don't know uh
you get the id i put it in bold um
so like the metric is the object of this
thing and so that is the question that
people are asking is they're saying get
me a metric like that is the fundamental
thing that they want
and there's a bunch of stuff that's
underneath metrics there's like tables
there's different logic there's
different like sources of where that
data comes from
people don't actually care about that
they're not trying to track that down
what they're trying to track down is how
do we define this metric give me the
metric as i understand it and so
while data teams have to worry about all
this stuff the people are trying to use
it and the people are trying to use the
olap cube really only care about the
thing at the top
so this is the first form of question
the second form of question is say in
the course of this board meeting people
say hey i think we should open more lego
stores
uh and so now people are trying to ask
questions of like how are lego stores
performing it's kind of this open-ended
exploratory question
so you want to look up basically what's
happening in lego stores and then the
question that people start asking is i
want a list of stores i want some data
that i can explore
but the way that they ask these
questions is i want a table i want
something that's just a list of objects
so give me a list of stores and again
you may get more detail about this there
may be things like with details about
their location or hours or data about
their sales and operating and things
like that but the point again with this
is like the noun in this sentence is
still the list of stores and so what
they're asking for
is a table where each row is some object
that they can understand like they want
to be able to look at a table and say oh
each one of these rows is a store
there's a bunch of dimensions and sort
of measures about these stores but i can
understand conceptually what each row is
like it's a very consumable way to look
at data and so this is typically what
people are actually asking for
they're saying get me a list of stuff
and i want like to understand what that
stuff is
this is where olap cubes run into a
problem which is
this table is not a table of anything
like it's very hard to actually describe
what you're looking at here because it's
kind of a list of objects
but not really because it's kind of this
like combinatorical combinatorial
abstraction where it's like kind of a
state but not really it's kind of a
month but not really if you've got
stores it's kind of stores but not
really it's also not really a list of
metrics like metrics are included but to
actually be able to compute like revenue
you've got to recompute it again it's
all broken apart it's very hard to
describe to somebody what this thing
actually is if somebody asks for data
and you send them this
it's like i don't really know what to do
with that like it's a difficult thing to
actually make sense of
and so the reason this becomes a problem
is we build a lot of uis on top of this
that basically display uis like this
and so this is an old bi tool it's a
modern version of it this is i believe
it's microstrategy
and you can see on the left these are
like the side the sidebar of fields this
is the way that this data gets presented
to users is via these sidebars of fields
and if you want to understand what
you're doing here like the way people
conceptualize this is they typically
imagine that there's a table underneath
this and like how am i manipulating that
table but if you look at these fields
it's really hard to actually understand
like it doesn't really make sense what's
underneath this the fields here are
things like i can't even read that it's
things like customer
day
item metric like what what table would
have inter like columns like this
doesn't really make sense of like what
the table underneath this actually looks
like similarly there's some metrics like
gross margins uh but there's also
metrics that are
average price per unit uh last year
margin like it doesn't in looking at
this if you're just playing around with
this as someone who doesn't understand
sort of the structure underneath it it's
hard to understand what you're actually
using here that you drag and drop a
bunch of fields into a chart but like
what is that being computed on top of
the way we think about data is tables
and there's not really a table here
there's like a hint of a table it's not
actually a table
and so i think that's one of the reasons
that this gets so complicated for people
to actually use tools like this is it's
not the way that we think about data
it's not intuitive to think about data
in this structure
there's another one down there that's
order account
um so
what happens with lab cubes is these
things are really hard to understand and
yet this is the way that we typically
ship data to people when they're trying
to do like bi work as we say here's an
olap cube with some ui abstraction on
top uh and people have to kind of
understand that data structure and it's
fundamentally a data structure that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so
people may be saying like okay cool olap
cube's great uh this was a thing from a
long time ago we've gotten rid of them
uh and to some extent that is true uh
like 10 years ago redshift came out we
now have things like bigquery we have
things like snowflake
today to be able to compute
uh data or like metrics on top of 12
million rows these databases can do that
very easily
they can also do that on top of 200
million rows very easily so in a lot of
ways like we don't actually need to
pre-compute anything anymore there's not
a need for this intermediate step to
improve the performance of of how
quickly these things are running
and so what that leaves us with is we
have a world that looks like this we can
just cross this off we say actually we
don't need this um that we can now do on
the fly queries directly against the
database without having to worry about
this intermediate step
and so this is like where what things
that happened ten years ago uh we got
rid of olap cubes
uh we have this chart like they went
away great no more roll up cubes why are
we even talking about this
we got rid of olap cubes as this like
materialized structure as a thing where
we actually run the computation to
compute that cube but we didn't get rid
of them in concept and so one of the
more modern bi tools that like sort of
initially pioneered this idea of like i
know olap cube bi tool is looker
and so if you think about what looker
does it doesn't actually get rid of the
olap cube it just sort of
does the computation in a different way
and so if you look or the way looker
works for those who don't know is you've
got raw data
so same as before
rather than defining an olap cube you
write this configuration language called
look ml that defines the relationships
between tables in your database so it
says hey you should join customers to
purchases in this way you can aggregate
these various like sales numbers up in
this way to compute a revenue metric
those sorts of things
when you define this in look ml what
happens then is that creates a ui in
looker's product that lets people pick
and choose these various metrics
and when people choose them in this drag
and drop ui
that gets passed back to the data model
which generates a sql query on the fly
and then that sql query is run against
the database
so rather than running in against this
intermediate step of pre-computed data
looker is just passing the whole thing
through back to the database
and then you get your results back as
you would in a classic bi tool
but if you look at this the way this
actually works is very similar to what
an olap cube does
that there is this definition in the
middle that says hey here's how we want
to aggregate this data up here's how
we're going to actually do this
reporting on it you get a ui out of it
and that ui is the thing that is get
presented to people to actually use it
and then there's like this transaction
back and forth between the reporting
layer and the data model that says this
is how we're actually going to use it so
there isn't an olap cube here in a
traditional sense but what look ml
effectively is is like a synthetic olap
cube it's a no lab cube that doesn't get
materialized
but it operates in very much the same
way
and so like this structure is kind of
the same that it's true it's not
materialized but it's still
fundamentally the same architecture as
what we had before it's just the query
to generate the olap cube happens on the
fly instead of happening like prior to
people actually doing all of this
reporting
and we see this all over the place so so
bi tools analytics tools all use this
architecture in some form or another if
you look at tableau tableau has tableau
extracts which are very similar to what
lookml is doing it's defined in kind of
a different way but you're defining ways
to actually aggregate and join data
together
when you do this extract that builds a
tableau ui where it has these same
fields on the left side
so this too kind of very similar
structure you've got the the extract in
the middle and then you've got the drag
and drop ui on the right
even mode as a product does something
similar so the way that we do this is
you can write a sql query on the fly
that sql query then gets loaded into an
intermediate data store where we put
charts on top where you can drag and
drop
so again kind of a similar structure as
as traditional overlap cubes
even some of the more modern stuff so
metrics layer tools like transform also
do something that kind of looks like
this so the way transform works uh you
define a bunch of metrics in the
transform uh like metric definition
language
and then you're able to actually
interact with that through code or
through other interfaces but you're
again interacting with this through the
kind of modeled layer that transform
provides and so again you end up with
with a very similar similar structure
what happens now because we've kind of
mirrored this olap structure we've
mirrored this concept of like hey we
define data up front that creates a ui
it creates way to interact with it uh is
we've ended up shipping that structure
to users over and over and over again
and so to to quote the same quote that
got quoted in the keynote this morning
this is a paraphrased version of
conway's law which is basically saying
you ship your org chart there's a
corollary to that which is like you ship
your architecture that the product
experiences that people have is a
reflection of the architecture
underneath it and if we are consistently
using an olap cube architecture even if
that architecture isn't
like actually materializing the olap
cube but is one that uses the same
concepts it uses these dimension and
measures concepts it uses this kind of
idea of pre-aggregating data whether or
not it happens on the fly or whether or
not it happens beforehand to actually
present the ui to users we end up
shipping the same kind of ui that we see
here which is a very confusing one for
folks if you don't understand that
underlying piece and so you actually see
this again reflected all over the place
where you see it in lookers ui they have
something very similar broken up again
by dimension and measures you see it in
tableau's ui you see it in mode ui
you even see it in in the transform
query language where it references the
same concepts and so like over and over
and over again we are using this same
concept which is fundamentally a
confusing one for the people who is
meant to to serve
and so like the reason for that is is
this the reason for that is that we
define these uis based on the technical
architecture underneath
that that we say okay olap cubes make
sense they do make sense for a lot of
reasons but we then end up shipping the
way that it's actually built for for the
way it's actually consumed and the way
that we should do this instead if we're
thinking about like the way we actually
want to serve the people who are doing
the the analysis and reporting is go the
other direction we should think about
like what it is that these people want
how is it that they actually consume
data and then make sure we're reflecting
those experiences back on the olap cube
rather than taking the olap cube and
reflecting it back to the end user
and so what does that look like uh the
ways that we should be doing this is the
same concepts i talked about before
these people think about metrics these
things
people think about data sets or like a
list of things and so we should be
reflecting those experiences back to the
olap cube rather than this kind of
abstract version of it that is the thing
that we've actually built
so for a final example of what i think
this looks like uh i'll go back to the
one time uh the one bit of my like
personal job history that sean didn't
mention uh which is i used to work at
this tank in dc they got some work to do
this year i guess um
uh
so i did a much like economic research
uh and so my job was to basically like
write reports about what was going on in
the global economy at the time that was
in 2009 so it was also a disaster uh and
so i had to work with a bunch of
government data sources and if anybody's
ever worked with government data sources
there are some that you learn to love
and some that you learn to like hate
uh
there were two that i really liked and
one that was terrible
one of the ones i really liked was this
one it's the st louis fred
it's the
federal reserve data from st louis or
the st louis fed data
it's like the kind of canonical place to
look up a bunch of economic data in the
u.s
the reason i really like it the reason
it's really easy to use is it presents
this data as just metrics it just says
hey here's a whole bunch of different
metrics that you might want to look at
like in this case it's got what treasury
maturity yields it's got federal funds
rate it's got like 30 000 other ones
whatever the number says on the side
but these things are organized just as a
metric like i don't have to think about
how do i actually create this i just
like look up the thing i want to define
if i want to find unemployment rate i
just look it up i find the table i look
at it it shows me a graph it's super
easy to use
the other like dead government data
source i really liked was this one uh
this is a screenshot of this from 2019 i
don't know how this is still actually up
in 2019. um this is from the imf so the
imf provides a bunch of data about like
economic
indicators across countries the way that
they provide this data is you choose
countries or regions you click a bunch
of check boxes
it shows you those metrics by those
countries it gives you a table or each
row is a country it's very
straightforward to understand
so this data is great the data from the
st louis fred is great because they are
organized by data sets or they're
organized by metrics and that's like a
very consumable thing and so i in this
point too i was also someone who never
learned sql i like was familiar with
excel i had attempted to use r but not
very well
that was like the way that i understood
data and that's pretty representative of
what a lot of people are who are using
bi tools are trying to do like that's
the level of technical expertise most
folks have and the thing that made sense
to me and the things that make sense to
them is a set of tables that i can
understand what each row means and a set
of metrics where i don't have to choose
like how to actually calculate it
the website that i actually hated was
the census uh this is actually the
modern version of this if anybody else
like tried to look at this in 2010 it
was something called the data ferret it
was absolute nightmare
if you know about that you know about it
um
i have no idea how to use this thing
like this this is effectively an olap
cube underneath it but it's got this
like data sets on the left but you can
choose different sort of filters and
there's these fields on the far left and
you can pivot it in weird ways and it's
like it's more flexible i guess but it's
again presenting this concept of an olap
cube back at me rather than just saying
like i want to find some metrics about
unemployment rate by state or by income
by by different geos i can't actually do
that i have to kind of think about what
the underlying data structure is for me
to make any sense of it and so i didn't
and so i like avoided this as much as i
possibly could uh and then i usually
give you a bunch of things you have to
like download micro data files and
nightmare
so this is the way though that bi tools
typically present data they use this
model rather than the previous two and
so that means because we have olap cues
whether or not they're in the old form
or they're not using more modern form
uh we end up with this kind of like
amalgamation of metrics and data sets
that doesn't really make sense it tries
to be both in one technically it's
probably more flexible but it's really
hard to use it's what drives a lot of
people to not be able to make sense of
the data they're looking at in in their
vi tools or analytics tools
a better option would be to split it uh
would be to say hey there are different
types of ways of looking at data rather
than trying to collapse this thing into
one let's present it in the ways that
people actually understand it present
some as metrics present data sets allow
people to split this up it may not seem
as clean we may not like have this sort
of perfect sense that everything is all
this nice one package but that's not how
people think about it when people are
thinking about data they're not thinking
about it all as one thing they're
thinking about it is hey i need to look
at a metric or i need to find a table
for a data set a table to explore
so uh after thinking about all this uh
the place that i now ended up was turn
of olap cubes is troubling uh this is
now the the stance that i guess i have
until the next time that this talk comes
up in which case i guess i'll feel
differently
but i'll stop there if folks have
questions that's all i got
[Applause]